dozens of people still missing in
Tennessee after America's deadliest
tornado outbreak in years at least 24
people killed so far officials say many
of the victims were asleep in their beds
when the storms hit the system shredded
buildings in Nashville before cutting an
even more destructive path east of the
city are lead national correspondent
David Beck know is in hard-hit
Cookeville Tennessee David good morning
what's the situation there Tony I have a
feeling you've never heard the type of
story we are about to share with you
this morning there was a home where I'm
standing the people who were in here
took shelter in their bathtub the
tornado lifted the house and I mean all
of it with the people in the tub and the
four walls around them they flew more
than 50 yards to the tree line behind me
the home obliterated but they survived
here's a picture of what the home used
to look like before the tornado now it's
just a hole there's not even a concrete
slab here the path goes on for nearly a
mile listen to them tell their story
this is Seth wells and Danielle Theo
files
I got woke up at 150 from my phone with
a tornado warning and that's when I
heard it it was as deep roar rumbling
sound that I've never heard before
we were flying in the air into the trees
back there where once we hit those trees
the house exploded just the house just
disintegrated you flew through the air
inside myself lifting and flipping over
Seth wanted to show us just how far they
flew in the air nearly 50 yards just to
give you an idea of how far it is from
where we're standing our truck lights in
the distance that's where their house is
what was that right there is the tub
that we were laying in oh wow I have no
clue how we survived I've seen houses
partially torn off I've never seen a
home essentially picked up and just
taken like Wizard of Oz that's exactly
right among the 18 people who died here
in Putnam County our Josh and Aaron
Kimberlin and their two-year-old son
Sawyer as well as four-year-old Hattie
Collins her parents Matt and Macey
survived
I have Danielle says her forehead was
split open requiring 15 stitches Seth
told us he has nothing but bruises they
are both so grateful to be alive I just
love how the two were you were just kind
of holding on to each other and then
after this not ever they didn't just say
that for the camera yesterday
Danielle asked Seth that he would marry
her he said yes Anthony David thank you
very much one of them one of the places
destroyed in Nashville was a place
called basement East really popular
concert venue they'd had a benefit for
Bernie Sanders on Monday night Tuesday
morning the place was gone but there's a
sign there that still survives says I
believe in Nashville